-♪ Ask the Fallons ♪
♪ Ask the Fallons ♪
-Hi, everyone.
-Hi.
-Thank you for sending in
all those questions.
-Seriously, thank you so much.
[ Laughter ]
-No.
-Isn't it thrilling to be back?
-Happy Valentine's Day.
-Yes, Happy Valentine's.
-We haven't done this
in a while.
"What song best describes
your marriage?"
Oh, you know what I think of?
-What?
-Today, you played it.
What song do you always sing
just out of nowhere?
You'll just --
-The Bonnie Raitt one?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Falsetto ]
♪ You won't believe it ♪
"Let's give 'em something
to talk about."
-I love that one, yeah.
I guess we are.
Or they're giving us something
to talk about here.
-I forget the plot
of the song, but --
[ Laughter ]
-Let's just say it's that
and hope for the best.
-We love Bonnie Raitt.
-Then we'll research later,
yeah.
-"Nancy, what's the most
romantic thing
Jimmy has done for you, so far?"
-[ Sighs ] I feel like I've --
-I'll hold it.
[ Laughter ]
I'll hold it.
-To me, one of the most romantic
things -- it was so insane --
was the flash mob
at the sushi restaurant.
-The flash mob was good.
We went to a sushi restaurant
and they were all actors,
but we --
It was your birthday
and we were in --
-Well, yeah.
So, it's my birthday
and I'm like,
"Please, no big deal."
I don't dislike my birthday.
It's fine.
I just don't need a giant party.
We're halfway through and this
-[ Laughs ]
-man gets up
and he starts singing.
-♪ Why do birds ♪
♪ Suddenly appear ♪
-And we're like --
-And we were like,
"This is so embarrassing."
We're,
He's about to propose!"
And then all of a sudden,
this woman walks out of the
bathroom and she's like --
♪ Every time you are near ♪
And then every table
started singing the song.
Then a tablecloth comes
off of a table we didn't notice
and a keyboard is there.
This guy is playing
the keyboard, doing the song.
Then the trumpet or saxophone
comes in from the kitchen.
-Trumpet player comes
out of the kitchen
with the chef.
♪ Wah ah ah ♪
-[ Scat singing ]
♪ Close to you ♪
-Oh, my God.
It was the most insane!
-You looked at me and I just
mouthed, "Happy Birthday."
-"What is your favorite board
game to play together?" Or --
-1, 2, 3.
-[Both] Scrabble.
-"What's the longest trip
you've ever been on together
and would you do it again?"
That France trip
was pretty long.
Remember when we woke up
the next morning?
-Oh, yeah.
That was really funny.
-I go, "Honey, wake up."
I go --
You go, "Yeah."
I go, "Honey..."
[ Laughter ]
-Like we're staying with --
-We're saying at this
-Place.
-nice place and I go,
"Honey...
-Oh, my God!
-...one of us wet --
-You shook me and you go,
"Honey, one of us wet the bed."
And I sit up. I go,
"First of all,
one of us did not wet the bed."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I was trying to say --
-I did not wet the bed.
-But if you did, you know,
I figured
get it out there,
get it out there now
and say like, you know --
-This is a thing?
-Yeah, we'll just make it easier
on you, so you don't feel bad.
-I'm like, "No, one of us
did not wet the bad.
Did you wet the bed?"
-It's soaking wet, on my side.
-Bed was like wet. Yeah.
-So it was probably me.
I go -- And I go,
Wait, this is --"
-This is so weird.
-This is -- I've ne--
And you go, "Honey.
-We went swimming last night.
We went swimming last night.
You went to sleep in your
swim trunks."
[ Laughter ]
-"One of us wet the bed"
is one of my favorite.
-"Who is the funniest person
in your family?"
-Franny!
[ Laughter ]
-Come on.
That was a loaded question.
They know the answer.
-Oh. "What is your favorite
candy bar?"
[ Hushed ]
You like that one.
-Yeah.
-It's not a Babe Ruth.
But it's named after --
-First of all, Babe Ruth
is not a candy bar.
-[ Laughs ]
-It's a baseball player.
-Yeah, but isn't the one
you like named
after a baseball player?
-No.
-Oh Henry!
Oh Henry!
-No! What are you even --
What?
I couldn't even tell you
what that candy bar is.
Oh Henry!? Who likes
an Oh Henry! bar?
-You like some avocadovo?
[ Laughter ]
-Clark.
-Yeah, the Clark Bar.
Ooh Henry Clark. It's not like,
"Oh, what are you
talking about?"
Not that different. Two names.
-They're totally
different names.
-Old-school names.
-Oh Henry!?
It's a phrase.
It's a sentence.
Oh Henry!? That's --
-What would be
my favorite candy bar?
It would be more of a sweet-tart
type of situation.
Oh, yeah.
I like hot tamales.
"Would you chew each other's
ABC gum?"
-[ Laughs ]
-I totally would.
-I would.
-Oh, yeah, hell yeah.
I wouldn't like just like,
"Ooh! Could I have that?"
-You would? Yeah, me too.
-But I wouldn't like want it,
but I would totally do it.
-Me too.
-Aww.
Happy Valentine's Day.
-I love you.
[ Laughter ]
-Happy Valentine's Day!
Have a good one, or don't,
and don't worry
about Valentine's Day,
-[ Laughs ]
-if you don't like it.
-What are you talking about?
Some people don't like it.
-Have a good one.
Well, just ending
on "Have a good one"
is a nice thing to say.
"Or don't."